[Music]
okay
so welcome to today's licensing
subcommittee to consider the application
for
a new premises license at
friends kitchen chip shop 162 king
street mansgate
my name is james plantsman and i'm
acting as the meeting facilitator in
order
to conduct the election of chair so at
least gonna have a nomination
i'd like to nominate councillor
bambridge super thank you very much
councillor
and is that second dude right yes it is
lovely okay in that case i'll hand over
you that's the bandwidge
um so over to you thank you
sorry
and welcome everyone to today's meeting
of the licensing support committee
prior to this weekend all participants
have previously checked
that they can be heard and seen and see
and hear other members
to double check this and to introduce
everyone who is present at this remote
meeting
i'd kindly ask that you confirm your
attendance and your role
or job title when i say your name um
mrs brock yes alison brock licensing
officer
um councillor wright yeah i'm here um
a member of the licensing committee um
councillor schwab yes i'm here and i'm
also a member of the licensing committee
ms phillips yes i'm here and i'm the
principal litigation lawyer for the
council
um thank you mr capstone yes i'm here
thanks chair democratic services
thank you um you see greg
yes i'm here pc greg uh licensing
officer for kent police
oh thank you um and dear martin
hi my name is
you okay and um
katie brewer hi there i'm here
democratic services
thank you have i missed anyone today
no okay if you have technical
difficulties during the meeting then
please contact casey
your classic services officer and call
who will attempt to assist you
on zero one eight four three five
she will put her phone number in the
chat function thank you
casey um i'd ask participants and you're
not speaking
please mute your microphone um just
minimizes background noise and we'll
help
everyone in listening to these buildings
microphones must only be one if the
participant has been granted does it
want to speak
the game my permission speak please very
briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking has
finished
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones turn silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls
whilst the meeting is in progress do not
turn off your phones in case you need to
be contacted
in the event of technical difficulties
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
ensure that you are in a quiet room free
from distractions for the duration of
the meeting
please note this meeting is being
streamed
um for members of the public except for
the private deliberation part of this
meeting
a separate a separate private hangout
meeting will take place for this element
of item
four and the public meeting will resume
in its previous digital location 30
minutes later
unless there is a reason to suggest an
earlier or later time
no unauthorized recording of the
confidential item of business is
permitted to take place
are there any apologies for absence
no any declarations of interest
no um okay so application for premises
license
friends fish and chip shop i call upon
miss phillips
the council's principal education
litigation sister to explain to the
party is the procedure that we will be
taking
during this hearing good morning thank
you
i'd like everyone to know everyone
present to know that the
decisions of the subcommittee are made
in accordance with the license in act
2003 and based on the information
presented in this agenda this morning
together with
any verbal submissions made today
decisions of the subcommittee are not
politically based
and the subcommittee will act
impartially
and offer a fair and unbiased hearing of
today's application
this subcommittee will give fair
condition consideration to everything
it hears and reads today um
as was said earlier we are here to
consider the application
of mr haki buyu ketas
a new premises license in respect of
friends
fish and chip shop at 162
king street ramsgate kent ct 11
8 pj under section 17 of the
in act 2003 the application
was made through an agent mr baiser
zephilic of sc license and legal
consultancy limited
at 84 hayes lane bromley kent
and the application of course is made to
thanet district council as the relevant
license in authority in accordance with
section 12 of the licensing act
um in relation to the further
proceedings we will hear the parties
in the following order the licensing
officer
and then we'll hear the applicant's
representative
as i understand the applicant isn't here
in person but
the representative will be in
communication with him
throughout this morning and then we will
hear representations from the police
each party has up to 15 minutes to make
its application
to make its presentation and this
includes any witnesses
you will not be allowed to introduce any
new evidence at this stage
that has not been disclosed um prior to
these proceedings
and if if there is an attempt to do that
then
i may have to interrupt you are not
expected nor required to talk for the
full 15 minutes however
following each presentation the members
of the subcommittee
may may ask questions of the applicant
and the representative
and there is no time limit for the
members questions
at the end of the proceedings each party
will have five minutes to make a closing
statement
in the following order the applicants
for the license
the representatives and the police and
please note to ensure that this virtual
meeting runs smoothly as was said
only one individual shall be allowed to
speak at
a time any person speaking must be
permitted to finish what they are saying
without interruption
interruption and i will direct
specifically who's speaking
by name at any given time the meeting
will then adjourn as was stated for a
subcommittee
to consider its decisions and to
deliberate on the evidence and
representations made
and when we adjourn the subcommittee
members the legal officer myself
and and the clerk will leave the virtual
meeting
if you'd like to hear the decision of
the subcommittee
i shall advise everyone of the decision
approximately 30 minutes from the time
of the
adjournment and if you choose you can
wait until then
you can either remain in the virtual
meeting during this time
or you can use the link again to access
to re-access the meeting
if you decide to wait in the virtual
meeting room please turn off your
cameras
and microphones to ensure your privacy
as the recording
will continue thank you
um thank you phillips um i'd like to
discuss the importance of following
this hearing procedure and that there
will be an opportunity for parties to
make a final
presentation after questioning therefore
i'd advise all presidents please follow
the procedure
and to respect those speaking by not
interrupting or speaking over others
if people do interrupt or speak over
others i as chairman will ask them to
refrain from doing so
if they continue to do so after my
warning then that individual could face
being asked to leave the meeting
um could the licensing officer please
present the report
morning everyone um we're here because
we've had a new application in for
a premises license at 162 king street
ramsgate
the uh it's a as i say it's a new
license and it's to sell
alcohol off the premises so it's not on
the premises
premises is a takeaway so it's basically
take away alcohol
and the hours that they've requested are
11 in the morning till 11 in the evening
and we've received the one objection
which is from the police
and that's the reason we're here today
so we would like your
decision on the application please thank
you
okay and thank you um would the um
applicant's agent
please present their application
good morning everyone um
we understand and appreciate the
comments made by the police licensing
and what would like to
set everyone's mind at rest as this is
the only representation
received i will be referring to that in
my presentation
um first of all i want to mention that
the fish bar is not located within
central harbour world
it is located with it within israel's
war
nevertheless the number of crimes in
this cliff world is similar to that in
central harbour ward
however i should note that there has
been only one anti-social behavior
crime on or near king street within the
last six months
according to the crime register and that
was in december 2020
we believe that mr bukatash will
contribute to the prevention of crimes
in the area
by having a responsible ethos it is the
fact that crime figures
are rising but it's not logical to say
that alcohol is the key factor
we see that there has been a major
increase in crimes after march 2020
when the pandemic broke down work out
um many studies show that economic
distress
is actually one of the main causes of
antisocial behavior
and a lot of people are suffering from
economic distress
nowadays due to the chronovirus outbreak
hopefully we will soon overcome the
pandemic and it will reduce the crimes
we are advised that the police and
community groups are taking steps to
prevent the crimes in the area and we
totally spot them
however the granting of an alcohol
license to apprentices
is not contradictory to these positive
steps
unless the premises can show that they
have taken robust arrangements
which is the case here we think that we
are prepared to
prevent problems arising from alcohol
sales
it is written here that enabling another
venue to sell alcohol
only encourages sales just because a
premises sells alcohol it doesn't mean
that they incurred sales or consumptions
of alcohol similarly a pharmacy does not
encourage sales of drugs
as a responsible business owner mr
hotkobu characters will not promote
alcohol in any way
and the premises will not be alcoholic
we believe that people who want to take
alcohol and drink
and want to take alcohol and drink
underneath by
park or any other public open space
would purchase alcohol from a licensed
convenience store in the vicinity
such as victoria of license holiday
or costcutters our offline off sales
will be ancillary to our food order
and will be made in sealed containers
preventing immediate
consumptions also there is no need to be
concerned about the granting of this
license
as it did not set the precedence for
other takeaways according to the
licensing act 2003 each application must
be considered on its own merits
nevertheless if that was the case this
application must have been granted
without the need for a consultation
period
as there are many licensed takeaways in
england
we do not expect the sale of alcohol to
increase the number of
our customers substantially therefore we
do not anticipate more noise
or alcohol-related disorders however
proper
signage will be displayed to remind
customers to be considerate
mr bukatash and many of his customers
live in the
neighborhood an increase in noise
and disorder would be detrimental to his
business
as well as the quality of their life
that is the last thing the applicant
wants
i studied youth purchasing alcoholic
drinks
there will be a challenge 25 policy in
operation
to ensure that alcohol will not be sold
to underage
customers or intoxicated people
as a personal license holder mr bukatash
can easily guess a person's age
and will ask for identification when
someone who appears to be under the age
of 25
attempts to purchase alcohol moreover
his experience within the food service
industry puts him
in an excellent position to identify
adults buying alcohol
on behalf of young people and prevent
them
there will be a cctv system covering
entrances
internal areas and external areas of the
premises
which will deter any possible problems
and disturbances
a well-run cctv protected shop will not
only enhance the area
it will discourage people from lingering
and drinking on the street
the cctv will be in operation constantly
therefore discouraging anti-social
behavior
moreover alcohol will not be solved if
this incitive is in operative for any
reason
the applicant is aware that he will be
responsible for minimizing the impact of
the licensing
and anti-social behavior by his patrons
within the immediate vicinity of the
premises
we believe the conditions like this
suggests are enough to minimize any
adverse impact
and we are open to discuss further
conditions that you may seem fit
i hope that i covered already i mean
every
issue and concerns regarding this
application however
if there is anything further than we are
ready to answer
thank you okay thank you very much um
does the licensing team have any
questions for the applicant's agent
no thank you chair okay do the police
have any questions for the applicant's
agent
not at this time though and do members
of the committee
and have any questions for the
applicant's agent
councillor shrug
yes i've got a couple um
can you tell me does uh the applicant
have any other food establishments
in the vicinity
[Music]
um does the applicant have any other
takeaway establishments in the vicinity
no he doesn't no um also um does he work
in the shop himself
yes he does work in the shopping spot
excellent
and what type of alcohol does he intend
to
supply because i've noticed that it's
only a little fridge that you've uh
aimed to have in there it's not as if
you can have optics up is it
yeah it's probably just beer and mine
basic stuff really
excellent that's all thank you thank you
um counselor right okay thank you chair
um could i ask the
the applicant's agent um is it the
intention
to only sell the alcohol with with the
purchase of food
or is or will anybody be able to walk in
and out to buy alcohol
and that's right the sale of alcohol
will be ancillary to a food order
no one will be able to buy alcohol
without buying food
thank you thank you
okay thank you and councillor right um
so if there's no other questions
um would the um police um please present
their case
good morning everyone um
the police have objected to uh this
application
um because the fish bar is located in
king street in ramsgate
um which the road itself experiences
one of the largest anti-social behaviour
across the fanuc district
um the anti-social behaviour stems from
a mixture of youth related offending and
disorder caused by
a cohort of rough sleepers the nighttime
economy with regard to pubs and clubs
also plays part when hospitality is open
alcohol is the key factor across
all elements um i have come up with some
stats which shows on the
on my objections the amount of asb calls
surrounding that area from october 2019
to october 2
2020. and obviously with the coronavirus
pandemic we saw
much of 2020 in the national lockdown
with subsequent local closures
however the demand upon police in
relation to asb
remained high with an increase towards
the end of the year
police have taken numerous measures to
crack down on the behaviour from
increased patrolling through
to the use of dispersal orders and civil
injunctions
our partners from youth services are
also engaged in outreach and
diversionary tactics in the area
the granting of an alcohol license to
this premises is contradictory to the
positive steps already undertaken by the
police and other community groups
the aim is to reduce alcohol consumption
and related nuisance
enabling another venue a fish and ship
shop to sell alco
to sell alcohol only encourages sales
and makes it more readily available
the fish bar is a takeaway only business
and the premises has no seating area
for customers to dine in an off sales
licence raises concerns in relation to
people taking alcohol away from the
venue to drink in the nearby park
or other public open spaces i'm also
concerned that the granting of this
license would set a precedence for other
takeaway venues to follow suit
which cannot be committed due to the
risk of disorder
and already the significant levels of
antisocial behavior in landscape
i understand you already operate until
11 pm 7 food to take away but with the
added sale of alcohol
this increases the potential for more
noise and alcohol-related disorder
it is a largely residential area so
there is an obligation to consider the
prevention of nuisance
to the local communities a public spaces
protection order
is already implemented and covers the
location of ramsgate town centre
there is also a pspo in place for the
whole of thanet district regarding the
consumption of alcohol in public places
they were brought in following public
consultation to restrict the use of
alcohol and reduce levels of asb
in public spaces the granting of an off
licence for takeaway alcohol again
contradicts those plans in place
at the location to try and protect the
public from asb
and alcohol related behaviours we do not
want to add to the issues just
rather reduce it boundary park is
directly opposite the road from the fish
bar
it is a hot spot for youth related asb
it is a congregated area and the police
object to any alcohol related
license particularly off-licence that
could potentially enable youth to
purchase alcohol
drinks or consume them there is also the
opportunity for them to in sight
encourage other adults to purchase on
their behalf
the fish and chip chop is too easily
accessible in that respect
and so that's my objection my concerns
are
that when people do go into the fish and
chip shop to order
a portion of chips that they are then be
able to take
buy a bottle of beer a can of beer and
take it to the bark
and drink um this is from 11 o'clock in
the morning through to 11 o'clock at
night
for me the fish and ship shop is you
walk in you get your food you walk away
we there is other off licenses if people
want to
purchase alcohol there is other off
licenses in the area
i don't feel the need that a fish and
chip shop needs to offer alcohol
when when ordering food and if there was
seating inside i totally understand that
you sit down for a meal have a drink i
don't feel the need
and to have alcohol being on on sale
whilst getting a fish and chips takeaway
so that's that's my representation chair
thank you
thank you for that um does the
applicant's agent have any questions for
the police
no thank you
okay do members of the committee
um have any questions um for the police
counselor none from me chair counselor
right
no okay um i just want you to ask and
um you said about setting a precedent um
i'm just wondering are there are there
many um
um like fish and chip type um
takeaways
um i don't know of any at the moment and
landscape does have a lot of takeaway uh
take away services
in the area we don't think there's any
that have an alcohol
license to serve alcohol to sell out of
sales alcohol
and this is this is our concern um
ramsgate already has a lot of pubs clubs
off licenses
um you know so i'm worried that if this
is granted it's just going to
have a rolling effect throughout the
whole of ramsgate takeaways
okay um
regarding these um these um asb calls
what you've listed
um obviously you know they they're
escalating since um
since the pandemic and our most of these
calls or are like a huge percentage of
these calls that are alcohol related
yes um so i've gone through the
statistics and these are all our asb
calls in the area and i would probably
say
50 60 are alcohol related youths
um adults uh disturbances
um yeah so i would just say yes
okay so the concern is about alcohol
related
yes thank you um
i would now like to um ask each party to
sum up
and make final representations each have
five minutes
and so um could i ask the police to sum
up
make their final statement again
my just to sum up if this license was
granted um like i've said before i would
be very concerned
that i understand what the agent is
saying that
we should all look at your um
application on
on its own but as police we are really
concerned that if this was granted
then we will have lots of other
takeaways in the area
wanting to sell um off sales alcohol
and ramsgate's already very high with
asb
alcohol related crime um boundary park
is literally
uh across the road from the fish bar and
it for me i'll just be concerned about
the more alcohol related
issues that the police would have to
deal with so
thank you okay
with the um applicant's aide um thank
you sorry with the with the atkins agent
um like to someone
thank you um i just want to say that
we understand the concerns of the place
but
having a well-rounded licensed premises
we don't believe it would like cause a
problem for the
area the crime figures are rising
due to the pandemic we believe and
the granting of an alcohol license as i
said would not set a precedence
there are some licensed takeaways in
bronzegate as well actually there is a
lot instance application
currently in place for an often off
license
with like similar hours to this
application
but as i said each application should be
considered on its own merits if the
applicant
is able to prove that they are well
equipped and
can prevent alcohol related problems the
application should be granted um
we said there will be hr 25 policy a
cctv camera
we do not expect our customers to
increase substantially
therefore we do not understate noise or
disorder
as a licensed premises the premises
holder
will be entitled to minimize the impact
of
licensing activities taking place
at his promises
and we are willing to uh collaborate
with the community
and the local businesses to support
the business in the area of a
well-rounded lifetime economy
and make essay make the area a safe
place for the general public
i think that's all thank you
thank you very much um so um
members of the subcommittee will now
leave this meeting along with the
council's legal representative
to deliberate this matter in private we
we shall resume
here to deliver a verdict in 30 minutes
time
whilst we leave the meeting i'll ask the
democratic services officer to explain
the retiring process
thank you jen okay so we will meet back
here using this
meeting link at 11 o'clock and so you
can
if you want to stay in the meeting or if
you want to close the
the tab and then go back in using the
previous um
hyperlink if you do choose to stay in
the meeting as the
legal officer mentioned earlier please
remember to turn your microphone and
your video off as the
live feed to youtube will continue um
while we're away
and okay so myself
and the legal officer and
the councillors will now go to a private
session to deliberate
and we'll meet back here at about 11
o'clock
so we'll see you then
okay so it's 11 o'clock and we're still
live streaming so i'll hand
over to um you councillor bambridge to
uh
call upon the next step okay and we'll
back yes
yep i believe so okay um
thank you jess i'd now like to invite
miss phillips and the principal
litigation solicitor
to read a summary of the subcommittee's
determination
thank you in the application of mr hooky
buyer curtis
in respect of a new license for the fish
and chip shop
at 162 king street ramsgate kent ct 11 8
pj
it is the decision of thanat district
council as the relevant license in
authority
in accordance with section 12 of the
license in act 2003
having considered representations made
to the license and subcommittee today
from the licensing authority um the
applicant
through his representative mr merton
and the police and also considering the
council's licensing policy
which includes specifically to reduce
crime and
disorder and reduce alcoholic misuse
the application is refused on the basis
that notwithstanding representations
made by
mr merton as to the measures that will
be put in place
to meet the licensing objectives it is
the view that
it still will will not prevent crime and
disorder
and is likely to increase anti-social
behavior in the area
it will not contribute to public safety
due to the anticipated increase
of anti-social behavior in the area it
will not prevent
nuisance in the area and it will not
protect children from harm especially
due to its
proximity and its location
of the licensing subcommittee